DeRozan ciacco got it
here's Van Vleet into the paint value
for balance use
[Applause]
tough shot by Lowry field to go to the
side now drives contact its new snore
[Applause]
all driving on an Adobe puts it up and
in
[Applause]
left Lake today and will not play
tonight or a game seven if necessary and
also obviously guilty beaks has been
suspended
Kyle Lowry will not let you miss it if
he's found I want to play
fabulous pass and the Raptors have their
first lead of the game wall down the
other way bothers the shot and the
Wizards get it back
feel for three
five seconds to play peel
gets in the lane puts enough chip
putting them to the free-throw line
hurdle
co-come the follow and the Raptors have
their largest lead of the game rebounds
but in five minutes and 45 seconds of
this quarter they have just seven points
Valanciunas scores inside work the
number one seed in the East for nothing
they were a very good team all year
the Wizards finish up their season going
out in the first round in six games four
games to two